previously on the walking dead but
you're just a scared little girl get the
[ __ ] over it problem
the boys been bit she she haven't
figured that out
look clear things what what hell
happened she could oh oh [ __ ] what do we
do
hey guys need to go - I'll do it
alright I don't wanna do it it's dark
I'll let you be Robin next time I'll let
you be Robin
[Music]
how's it going red
my name is Peter Pat welcome back to
some more Walking Dead holy [ __ ] bro
we're back on the train and we're
talking to claiming bed that was just
sad episode 4 climate what happened why
did Chuck Thanks
oh that son of a poor commie
how the [ __ ] can you say that your
little girl well I better now how you
doing hey you're [ __ ]
you don't talk to my girl my girl just
stay away from her I'm not your sunny
like she was gonna die that she was
gonna end up like duck why did you go
and do that though she is I don't know
much about you folks
sure the sun's gonna come up tomorrow
and y'all keep going on like this and
that girlie
[ __ ] you man I know that you have a
goddamn plan we get to Savannah and then
what find her parents well find a boat
ride a boat you think that's a new idea
you got even the buggiest idea about
where you're gonna find one of those
well do you sit down with the girl and
hash it out find a mat for Christ's sake
I'd give you one of a headache and if
something were to happen to you it won't
if it were you gotta prepare the girl
teacher to use a way I don't know about
that but that here for criminy it's just
a little girl girl and she'll die a
little girl if you treat her like one
you gotta consider her a living person
that's yet you're either living or
you're not
you ain't little you ain't a girl you
ain't a boy you ain't strong or smart
you're alive now her hair got down a rug
playing with a mop that's gonna act like
velcro to any hands swinging its way
buying some scissors in my pack and take
care of that hair before a walker does
it for you I don't need to be lectured
by a truck enemy as a gun just like it
or not that's what saves your life from
here on out
but too many people have died already we
have seen another little girl die Mike
doesn't do me I hear you play it a
haircut and a gun it's a good advice all
right that something you got any family
living fairly out there somewhere Ben
saw it on my own for the past 14 years
now I'm sorry to hear that
no wonder blame alrighty then where are
you headed then huh
that way I mean when we get to Savannah
we got a few ideas will ever talk when
we get there about whether or not you
folks want company
he's safe up here so so he literally has
no [ __ ] plan and he's judging me for
not having a plan that sounds about
fricking right what about Kenny Kenny
what's up you and me let's just get to
the ocean all right man
I'll talk to you later you talk to you
later Kenny I'm here if you need me man
I get it man let's go to Clemmy
unless Ben has something to say Ben is
this such a knee
he doesn't do anything you know Carly
didn't have to die you know she would
have killed me instead yeah see you see
you Ben how the [ __ ] did you get to that
pose all right let's go over that go to
the boxcar I know it does let's go
where's this whiskey maybe we can give
her the Kenny should cheer him up it's
kind of obvious you just sitting there
all right claiming what's up did you
talk to him yeah I did
have the pine sofa made some good points
but I don't like him sell we're not
gonna let anything bad happen to you but
there are some precautions we have to
take okay yeah that makes sense
I'm glad you understand climbing
sweetheart okay what should we do I
think we need to find a matter of a plan
for when we get to Savannah teach you
how to protect yourself better tidy up
of it so you can't get grabbed so easily
I'd like that
all right I'm glad you understand
clinically I think we need to learn how
you to protect yourself I don't like to
see the climbing we need to know how to
protect yourself like hiding or running
away no gonna be like this first don't
be afraid of it it's just a thing take
it why it's really say that it's all the
time and don't put it on the trigger
unless you want to hurt somebody you'll
get stronger the aim you look right down
the top through that
line up the sight at the end with your
target is there anything else I should
know
no well aim for the head I guess these
are just bucks but you have to aim for
the hair Wow not a walker yeah Thank You
Hertz then see the minute dick you know
I don't want to think about that you're
right
might be a lot for your first day you
ready you ready you ready clearly his
freakin eyes are so scary
alright Clem let's shoot this bottle
dude careful now
hide you [ __ ] yeah let's take your first
shot squeeze the trigger smoothly and
I'll cover your ears bad as Clemens the
kid is little Kevin let's stick with it
okay alright same animation huh alright
so aim a little more left a little bit
more - a little higher girl fan clan
good job okay
what else we got climbing clue
all right keep it steady
a little hiring a little harder Oh
clearly you and me clinical ooh we can
kill all the zombies in the world
that's right all right here we go steady
now good job I just pretended they were
Walker head
that's good thinking guys like you see
they're not walkers though no far from
it but you know how these things work
there
good job graduate you two walkers one
day okay I feel good
good job cleaning what a waste of
bullets though I mean I think we need
those you talk Clementine to protect
your son all right what do we got here
is live dear one we got something in
this thing what Oh interesting
what do we got over here
is this from yeah this is from duck poor
duck man
I guess we'll cut her hair I don't
really want to cut her hair hi I just
want to make sure she lives so here
probably not gonna like this Oh what
happened nothing we have to talk about
your hair it's not safe that's not nice
are you seeing it smells no of cars that
cuz it does kinda no I don't like lamb
did you were my bed of Handy st. John
grabbed it and I got man yeah well that
could happen again and if it's a walker
we need to trim it
just a trim right sure I need to cut it
short enough so that again get grabbed
okay okay let's dead if we do this film
I guess not
mo it's a good thing you look super cute
plenty don't worry I got this
he knows what he's doing I've trip a lot
and now impossible so you did kill
someone before uh yeah yeah glad you
finally told me me to say she looks good
like that lots of things now it doesn't
even matter
well killing is always bad Clemmy how it
is
yeah killing is bad no matter what are
you doing now to protect yourself and to
protect me
yeah doesn't make it good but you have
to I do it because it's necessary
walkers own people okay
think I'm about done as clanks probably
tear these species back with something
here I have some hair thingies Oh hair
thing is awesome cutting that's nice of
you Lily
oh good job climbing clear I don't even
know what to do about oh it's a door no
don't be like that
dumb nice yeah look cute and a lot
harder to grab don't beside climbing you
look really nice ah she doesn't like
yeah I'm sorry
well her hair is a lot safer let's talk
to her a little more about your hair I
think it looks cute though my mom isn't
going to like it
what a crappy day huh crappiest the crap
can go either would you be seeing I
don't know if I would have taken you
with me I probably would have run out of
food
dan dear stop with me I'm glad I came
with you I'm guided in climbing and
going to look around for a look around
for a few things that will make sure
we're prepared when we get to Savannah
that would be good
I hope it's safe there it's it for you
to meet all right let's try and give the
whiskey to Kenny I guess you're just
gonna sit there
this is problem man alright Kenny yeah
there's a map right there so let me know
if we're getting closer you see anything
I don't know what's going on let's check
on this dude maybe it's his whiskey oh
yeah we can give a sample right Jim
didn't realize I had it left
well it's been a pretty obvious spot to
nip one Annette no thank you
nut I'm fine I'm fine yourself
hmm anybody in there wanna share a drink
you let him know I think I know one I
think I know one
it's full of maps and documents all
right totally looks like a map can I
take it that if I get by you for a
second kidding
can you just leave me alone like then go
and talk to Chuck then Chuck wanted to
know if you needed a drink
he's got so yep yeah
well choice Kenny better tale
thanks a to man I think so too
let me just grab that ha ha ha
and where Adam here what I was the
fastest zip I've seen in my entire life
you don't zip that in Sweden do you holy
[ __ ] that's the fastest Dipper
all right let's teach climbing the map
and I think that was buddy what I was
the one giving the bandit supplies oh I
[ __ ] I see oh oh oh I gotta kill you
I'm gonna [ __ ] murder yet do you know
how much I went through to get Carly
back dear I kill you kill I [ __ ]
Kelly Anna Casillas
I could toss you over right now I'd be
done with no I please why should not
yeah why watch it I didn't know what to
do please please
okay lady don't do it I was just kidding
Lele Lele Lele all right
I even this Sara I'm one great bet you
did that son of a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got Carla kid College Ted
Lily's dead even [ __ ] duck is dead
and then kaca is dead how many people
are gonna die so sad I know they're not
even real a bit high it still makes me
sad
alright let's go through the land super
meet you and what we're gonna do when we
get there we don't know what to expose
in our pants from Savannah bad I was in
Savannah true pretty terrible's you and
I were a team you know and a team needs
a plan aside from everyone else on this
train stops you and I should know
exactly what we're doing
plan I like it good all right so maybe
you should be look for her pants I think
we should look for your parents I guess
yeah you don't know if they're okay what
happened that's gonna be interesting
sure they're okay
I don't think so stay positive trying to
stay positive let's look at the myth
night now if we can figure out where
they were we can start there
looks like we'll come right through town
if there's nothing on the tracks to hold
us up we've had a good chunk of Savannah
here
hey we'll figure it out now I acclaiming
clean up in there once think about it
the hotels on here read this map it
maybe it'll jog your memory
we've got really tasty dessert something
is this it the marsh house yes that's it
all right
yes you think we have a good play I
think it's very good ah can I tell my
parents you know yeah I don't really
know actually but
go ahead climb there what you want to do
all right how do you feel good better
I'm glad we have a plan and you're a
good little chef
and your head we should see how far oh
[ __ ] what's going on it's a probably a
walker I don't like this wow what is it
whoa that's not good that's definitely
not good for Kenny maybe we could walk
that's [ __ ] stupid we got a goddamn
train things not full of milk Charles
that's gas or diesel something that's
gonna explode things John got to get a
hold of yourself this a crew here yes
yes this yes yo screamin like that
you're gonna get your face chewed off
are you guys gonna be trouble because we
could have just kept walking all right
we're friendly yeah we're friendly put
your head down kid that's what everybody
says let's get these guys a break we'll
see you guys got a problem with your
train yeah yeah you're standing right in
front of it dude
it's a wreck it's not so bad from up
here send your buddy up to have a look
why anything goes sideways up there we
won't let them escape
all right Prez gotta end this episode
here but I can favorite deputy I enjoyed
this guy come with red today and I'll
see you next episode
over there have you read mm-hm gonna get
this Manny but I don't I don't really
know what I did to deserve it
but hey I I'm thankful for you at least
especially now that I went through the